Now, I take another sensor reading.
By the way, I just copied over,
see the low, the density on the bottom.
I just copied over,
that's the belief that the robot has.
The robot sees another hole.
So that means p of z given x is
the same thing I had before,
because I got the same
reading I had before.
I saw a hole.
And again, I multiply.
But this time, I multiply
the previous density by this and
you'll notice now that the robot
has a lot of belief, okay?
That it's actually where it really is.
And the reason is,
is it saw a hole, it took a meter,
it took a step of two meters,
saw another hole.
Megan's really hoping,
I don't go another two meters.
I won't and just that amount
of information is enough for
it to have a pretty good
belief about where it is.
Okay?
There's still some probability
that it's over here,
because if that previous
reading was just wrong and
the current reading was right that
I might be there, same over here.
If the current reading was right,
but the previous reading was wrong.
No, the other way around.
In, anyway, the, the idea's that it's,
it's weighting these
different probabilities.
Okay?
And you could, you know, do it again.
So you resample and
you move and you see here,
we have the resample density where most
of its belief is in the right place and
there's some densities there and
that's it.
And that's the way a particle
filter works, okay?